[Music]
boom what's up everyone welcome to
simulation I'm your host Don sake on
super-pumped to be talking about
abstraction and creativity
we have jeremy nixon joining us on the
show hello hello thank you so much for
coming on brother I'm super pumped oh
absolutely
so much to talk about this episode is
gonna be epic Jeremy's background for
those who don't know he's a machine
learning researcher at Google brain
dedicated to understanding the
principles underlying information and
intelligence with a focus on abstraction
creativity and alignment and you can
find the links in the bio below AI dot
Google as well as desist creativity
dot-com website and the modeled systems
website as well as which is actually a
Google Doc which has a bunch of cool
stuff in it and the LinkedIn profile to
Jeremy as well check out those links
let's start things off with one of our
favorite questions to ask our guest
Jeremy what are your thoughts on the
direction of our world well thanks so
much for having me it's an absolute joy
to be here as far as the direction of
our world is concerned when I was in
school I wanted to write down my
worldview as much detail as possible and
realize that there were umpteen values
that I thought were worth instantiating
in the world and so to the degree that I
could take the direction that our world
had been on say in creating technologies
that enabled the you know advances in
the industrial revolution and in really
like creating computers and
computational machines and machine
intelligence there's a sense that
there's a potential to solve all
problems using machine intelligence that
was extremely potent and so I certainly
see and the future of machine
intelligence as the thing which
basically will have a very long term
impact on like what the world will look
like so I have a sense of that direction
is very important in a live my life with
that direction as a function of its
importance
and there is you know so there are
umpteen other directions in the world
that are worth looking at but um that
for me turned into the primary thing
because really foundational you care
about what is like the highest leverage
you know you make a small change and
there's this cascade where the world
takes a dramatically different turn as a
function of the actions you took you
want to know what set of actions look
like that and make sure that you take
the actions that are correct in that
case
ill the would like you just said the
machine intelligence moment with
civilization is about to be just the one
of the most critical transitionary
periods of our trajectory and so for
your fascination at an involvement in
the time period is something that drives
you I want to know on the journey side
of things okay
born in Waco Texas moved outside of
Detroit after that and who were you as a
kid that got you hooked into science
well um easy answer is that I grew up
with books more than I grew up in a
particular place dad was thus English
professor in so it's reading day in and
day out obsessed with umpteen characters
so I guess certainly like Hermione
Granger was my first love there was a
you know body of science fiction books
like Ender's Game where these boy
geniuses are tasked and are also like
genetically set up to basically like
fight for humanity against this bugger
race I was really interested in this
this kind of archetype is you know chow
extremely intelligent using their
capacity to have you know extraordinary
impact and so I think that that was
somewhat formative their way of the
games when I played it was very
obsessive child so I think when I was
eight or nine years old I could play
pokemon silver by sound in that you know
if you know the map if you've memorized
it you can hear where you are when you
are when you're moving around and that
you know like natural memorization a
natural obsession carried on so I'm team
loves of mine things like you know
reading and it's like a PDA like when I
was in fifth grade my teacher like very
lovingly let me just read all of class
and instead of participating in it so I
got yeah just I threw a huge amount of
things that were fascinating to me at
the time that way
and then when you realize that you could
like okay you're pursuing so many things
that are fascinating you but then how
did you know that you wanted to go into
this next step at Harvard and pursue
applied math and CS yes but was far from
obvious when I was at school as
interested in optimal decision making an
optimal behavior so the fascination was
with this sort of econ archetype the
thing that that knows its goals and that
has some representation of an action
space and can objectively basically
derive the optimal course of action in
order to accomplish whatever it is that
it's set out to accomplish and I was a
bit horrified by myself so there there
are these beautiful ideas in game theory
you know you can watch the rational
agent taking you know optimal actions
and there's a strategic behavior
there's always interested in strategy
from one as a kid you know like reading
about you know the the exploits of you
know extraordinary like you know genius
like warriors and battle basically lots
of these generals with strategies that
were fascinating to me I was like
playing civilization and I was thinking
oh well like in the design of the
civilization like how do you optimize it
for like max culture or form for
conquering or whatever and so in all
these games you're trying to execute
some strategic behaviors and you have
these sort of patterns of action that
are very powerful but as a person you're
experiencing all of these emotions that
feel at least made mind like they're in
the way of like optimal action and so
basically the heuristics and biases
literature like I got hit with it when I
was in high school now in the sense that
there's like confirmation bias that
there's this sort of attentional
heuristic but there is hyperbolic
discounting you know you discount the
future much much more than you should
all of these sort of horrified me
because I wanted to be able to think
correctly I think properly and it was
clear that I was far from being able to
like act as if I was an agent you know
act as if I was you know a great
character in one of these books or as if
I was going to sort of execute strategic
behavior in a game what
um you know basically you know let me
feel like I had done things properly and
so going in I was mostly interested in a
mathematical approach to economics and
mechanism design right so like yeah
basically how do I personally behave
optimally how do I create optimal
systems so like how do it's like inverse
economic strain where a mechanism design
you try to create to the incentive
structure that gives you the outcomes
that you're interested in in the system
and by sort of tweaking you know here
stick like say using money in order to
transact rather than bartering or um
basically like be a veteran of crypto
can be seen in part as like this
mechanism design problem we created a
set of inceptive that make it possible
for us to to transact in a different way
abstract over value in the world those
seemed incredibly powerful and you know
the evolutionary mechanisms that design
societies and the design biological
organisms those mechanisms are
generative and they're powerful so I was
thinking a lot of ways mostly about game
theory and mechanism design and applied
mathematics was an attempt to formalize
different kinds of a really economic
algorithm and that would be capable of
creating the kind of world that I
thought we should live in yeah so both
optimizing your own best self in the
world as well as the world around you
optimize that system yeah yeah you can
you can tell from the childhood through
the Harvard years that this is like so
you like hard core yeah okay so it was
applied math CS and economics all so you
ended up becoming a top ten player in
the country in college ultimate which
you only actually started when you were
a freshman right so you became am you
beat you got to like a level of mastery
in this in just two years yeah that's
right
so in part the question for me was is
there a way for me to turn myself into
the well really it wasn't about becoming
greatest player into a player that
changes the game in a dramatic way where
I was creatively experimenting with
umpteen forms of throw where I
put myself into training regimen that I
designed myself in an attempt to to
basically create a kind of playstyle
play that was extremely dynamic but it
was also very grounding so basically I
put in extraordinary amounts of work day
in and day out and watching myself
become more quickly it was this well
very general sense that I was capable of
turning myself into something that it
was worth being and so um basically this
is a very obsessive mentality right it
was like the same person who's like
playing this video games so much that he
memorizes it he knows them that happen
intimate detail yeah it's playing golf
but it's like forming himself into you
know sort of you know optimal player
that's what much as possible you're
practicing down and there's a context
the context for growth and it's like a
very fast feedback loop yeah where I had
basically systematically read the
literature and performance and in
basically the mental toughness a mental
game and for example like I would deeply
visualize every single extraordinary
play that I had had for a 5 minutes band
before each practice and then we come to
practice in the state of mind of a
person who had executed all of those
boys playing Z and the sense that there
were like a number of techniques which I
could experiment with which would
dramatically improve my performance that
wasn't still it was grounded right so it
was obvious to me that it worked well
and I'm feeling like things like that
have been useful like throughout the
crossfire and this is another example of
you hyper optimizing your efficiencies
and you were gonna talk about some of
these things later but one of the ones
that you just mentioned was coming in
with that mindset of visualizing your
previous hyper successes in the past and
kind of you're preparing and priming
yourself for a very successful practice
or competition ok so then afterwards
after Harvard you read machine learning
textbooks I love I love humans that just
are like I'm obsessed with something so
I'm just gonna do that thing and then
I'm just gonna be able to implement
machine learning algorithm said the
companies that I go to cuz I'm right
yeah to teach us about that and then how
you move to the Bay Area did spark got
into Google brain yeah yeah so it was a
follow on from a like really strong
shift so I hadn't really done any CS in
college when I was finishing my junior
year I had this the sense that the thing
that was most worth doing was basically
asking like what is the future of
machine intelligence going to look like
and what is most important thing to to
make sure happens in that context and so
in order to basically understand it well
um I knew that I would need to get
rounding in computer science so I
basically took my senior year and I
threw myself through the entire computer
science curriculum as well as I could at
Harvard and it was extremely difficult
in a big dense and compressed version of
that curriculum but I came out of it
with a sense of that if I like read this
set of texts I could get basically a
position that would give me projects
from which I could get access to these
sort of elite machine learning research
works and the play was out of notes so
days it was summer at Harvard and I put
myself through basically the basics of
Python programming like learning Python
the hard way followed by Python for data
analysis you know like looking at these
linear algebra libraries like numpy and
like data representation of libraries
like pendous into like intro to
statistical learning with applications
in are basically an intro to basic
machine learning algorithms not at the
level of detail that would let you
implement them but that would tell you
what they were and i gave you examples
and like sort of exercises that you
could do and finally into the elements
of statistical learning which is this
more grounded text where you'll get a
presentation of an algorithm that's at a
level that you could like implement the
details of the algorithm if you say have
a linear algebra library and from those
text books I wrote my own machine
learning library with sort of scratch
implementations of of every major
algorithm in the space
from random force training boosters
everything that I would basically need
to know if I had been like doing a you
know graduate program and Michigan
learning or something like that and in
writing the library you're right next to
the algorithm and the code is so close
to fajn where you can start doing
research with it because we're sitting
there with this implementation right and
so if you decide you know to take your
clustering algorithm and update in a
slightly different way you can just
write that down and it'll work and that
was fun of those fascinating I loved
that but it gave me this foundation and
so I you know moved to the bay at the
time without a position and wrote down
ways in which I could converse with
people that would basically get me
referee references to the organizations
that I thought I should be a part of and
so like basically contrarian truths
about every major machine learning
algorithm so that like whatever you know
algorithm came up I could tell you some
fascinating thing about you know the way
a random forest is incapable of
generalizing outside of domain or you
know the way of some like linear model
is more capable of generalization than
anything what's previous to me basically
like I'm writing down these interesting
facts in the face of the conversation
about them being able to be fascinating
and leveraging that inter referrals to
to organizations that basically would
let me build out these sort of like
large scale machine learning guns that's
interested in me and the applications
for these like you said at the very
beginning this transitionary period
we're in with machine intelligence the
next slide that we have Ronnie we have a
application slide here and it's just
endless the applications and currently
this is convolutional neural networks
that's man and what's our and and it's
recurrent neural net we have three
current networks this is sequence could
be across time and it's like a sort of
reframe where I give a long input as
opposed to a single input and it takes
it in and we're currently processes it
so like the first letter for example in
a sentence followed by the second letter
followed by the third letter
and it will basically go through each
input and do the same transformation
over it but lets you look a sequences
room and put instead of a sort of static
static value okay so a convolutional
network would be for an image it's a
static but a a recurrent neural network
would be for a six set like a sentence
and letter-by-letter
so like an L examples is an O and okey
okay so like an audio stream in speech
recognition in question-answering you
have this sort of query and whatever
question is which is usually a sequence
in machine translation you have a
sentence or a phrase whatever it is that
you're translating all these are usually
treated as sequential inputs and so okay
like at that time you know
well standard our nets were the
state-of-the-art in those tasks yeah
yeah but these are application me see if
I can oh yeah this quick is just that
yeah with so Reap recurrent recurrent
neural networks within that it's almost
as though after every single letter of
input there's like a recalibration
that's occurring with the best possible
output yeah that each inputs the best
possible chocolate that's right and then
with a convolutional neural network it
just takes in the entirety of the image
and then it starts and we have it in the
next slide as well as just that it
starts then building out the the things
like pixels edges shapes parts objects
yeah well really the beautiful thing is
that all of this is derived from the
data and so like this notion of parts
like we have a concept for this sort of
object being decomposed like you know
your face has a nose and some eyes and
mouth like we have we have words for
those things but the algorithm that's
attempting to do facial recognition will
learn from scratch in a lot of ways the
sets of features that are predictive of
the output and so they're umpteen
concepts in here that we don't have
words for where it's discovered some
interesting and predictive concept
inside of whatever our data it's
attempting to classify and that
generality is extremely powerful where I
won't necessarily understand you know
the the sort of details of an image that
like predict whether it's
it's a dog or it's it's a Lenore it's
Jeremy or whatever but it will discover
from the data those features and and
that paradigm is extremely powerful like
one reason there are so many
applications is that you just give it an
input in an output and it will find the
representation of the input that is
optimal and it's being optimized for
predicting the output and that is a
powerful you know reframe and paradigm
shift in how to do something like
classification and and this was you were
you were extending api's for data
scientists to use machine learning
resources that's more exactly okay
so i'm i basically was interested in
creating machine learning libraries and
one of the few took the time machine
learning libraries that still needs lots
of development was sparks ml bed library
so spark has this like large-scale an
open source like big data compute
framework so for doing the lightning
fast compute and most people will use
Hadoop to distribute their data that's
out of Google right ah
and then you spark to do compute on top
of that distributed data store and it's
machine learning library ml Lin had a
sort of paucity of machine learning
algorithms and so the opportunity that I
wanted was basically to implement these
algorithms you know from scratch net
scale and gain a very intimate
understanding of how they work yes
okay and then enable so many other
people to use the resource that's
exactly right so I guess now you can do
sort of like a large-scale image
analysis on huge amounts of data you
know with sort of this native SPARC
implementation of convolutional neural
networks that's right that's right okay
okay and this is kind of like the
democratization of the machine
intelligence which yes okay this is pre
tensorflow so and this is pre tensorflow
- yeah so tensorflow is the most popular
machine learning language right now yeah
that's right library library yeah yeah
and then is that quite like modular like
component based or is it how is
tensorflow for use yeah so
they it's both modular and has many
different AP is depending on the level
of granularity and level control that
you want of your machine learning
process so can it be as simple as like
me saying that I want to classify images
and me adding a component of a block of
tensorflow code that enables that to
occur yeah yeah exactly so if you want
to classify images there's a very
they're very high level API it's like
Karis is a good example of a very high
level API where you'll just say you know
here the layer types that I want you
don't specify any mathematical
operations but Ezzor flow allows you to
go you know all the way down to raw
where if you want to say specifying like
exactly what every matrix that exists
and exactly what operation to perform it
can also do that and there are different
ways to interact with it at these
different levels of analysis we're at a
high level you'll have say like a skill
like convolutional layer but within it
will be obtain different operations that
you could specify yourself if you want
to but in basically abstracting all of
them into a single line you have a much
simpler experience if you're like you
know a user trying to figure out how to
set up your classification other part of
the ethos of Google brain is that all of
you get to set your own research agendas
and you disseminate your research in a
way that it's helped for a healthy
exchange of ideas globally yeah and I
think that's a major part a major key
for our future so the last
year-and-a-half at Google brain you've
been spending a lot of time on
abstraction creativity I'm really
excited to talk to you about these
things let's start things off with the
abstraction of what is a world view
adjustable generating a world view and
intentionally building yeah world yeah I
think that's worthwhile so I'm naturally
world views a very high-level concept
and people will have different
instantiations of that high-level
concept so so one instantiation at least
the one that I generated glass trying to
write mine down was that my world view
is about the values that I hold which
are there's some set of concepts that
feel like they're consistent you know
across my life and that are grounding my
decision
okay it can peer can you observe
yourself you ask well what values am i
living out on a daily basis right
alongside you know basically what do I
think is worth doing so like what goals
make sense in light of my values and in
a lot of ways these goals are asking how
do I lie in my world with my value
system in practice they're like better
and worse answers to that question but
we're another instantiation of worlds
view could look like sort of like a
philosophical worldview where you ask
well like what do you think exists at a
fundamental level and every concept that
we throw around is something that we are
willing to think with and that we're
like willing to imply exists for the
purpose of deciding what to do and
deciding how to communicate how to act
as well as you know like how do you
think you can sort of reach truth we're
like scientific worldviews have sort of
like wrested control from this you know
sense that for the most part people
weren't it types like mystical world you
or let's we're really just worldviews
we're like the path the truth was about
being in touch with the spiritual with
something transcendent supposed to sort
of grinding out in a some experiment
some set of experiments that like let
you do causal inference and you know
there's this tragedy in that like the
paths the truth differ dramatically
across domain when some domains it's not
possible to do anything that looks like
science where you have a clean
experimental method and the attempts to
extend science to those domains has been
met with struggle and challenge or
domains where like mathematics fails you
know if all these chaotic Duren complex
environments where we actually don't
have models that officially predict
whatever is happening in those domains
and in those contexts you still have to
make decisions and so in practice you
end up with a path the truth that's much
more heuristic it's like oh well this
kind of worked in the past so let's try
it again
or some you know great leader trying to
do it this way and it worked once so
we're gonna do it the exact same way
over and over again but in the absence
of quality paths the truth it's very
easy to get stuck in social feedback
loops and even in the context of science
you'll have you know something like
Thomas Kuhns paradigms where there are
body of you know like different socially
accepted paths
to accomplishing some goal in like the
context I machine learning say you like
have you know connectionism which is you
know really really where I said so
Google brain mostly works on deep
learning you know along with sort of
open the eye and deep mind and if you
like academic research labs the many
labs work on other forms of machine
learning which have very different
philosophies around like what's likely
to succeed and like around why they
succeed so it's very clear that there's
also sort of like sociological effects
and something that's closer to and the
science but outside of the context where
you have a clear empirical feedback it
can well I can get really gross so
there's this version of worldview that's
like oh well like what do you think
exists how do you get the truth and what
are your answers to foundational
questions of meaning or worthiness or
Richard or whatever I want to hear your
thoughts on so ok yeah we're we're it's
of course it's not super
the compartmentalised like I'm about to
describe it but I want to know
approximately how much weight you give
every part of this aspect of worldview
development okay the the lineage of
ancestors that brought you into the
world okay and then let's say you're
born okay so with those genetics the
lineage or ancestor yeah so like parents
grandparents grandpa yeah yeah and all
of the and all of the microbiome that
and four biomes all this stuff right
okay then I want to know how much way
you give that compared to how much
weight you give maybe like the first
couple years of the foundational
infrastructures of your input stream
being turned into your brain and your
understanding of the world right yeah is
that the developmental period and then
two adolescent years and the adult years
like do you put any of those at a higher
weight than the others yeah I mean like
the natural response is that the
preceding experience initializes the
next right so from your ancestor you
will inherent some mechanism for
deciding and that can be much more
powerful in that it's a generator of
your featural worldview then if you if
you take particular facts so you know if
you're say like raised with parents who
like believe in sort of scientific norms
you're not with a different sense of
what the right path the truth is and so
you know when you're like an adolescent
or when you're an adult the way in which
you decide to bring something in or to
you know reject it it will come out of
the way you've been initialized right so
that said they're like you know portions
of my life in which I feel like I'm
experience faster growth and I think
that they're pretty powerful transition
periods that I can identify as like
dramatic updates in my own thinking
about what I should do or what's
worthwhile or who I up and you can
really like look at the life changing
process
as like being mediated by a few simple
factors so I had a few instances where
there were dramatic shifts and the
people that I was around I think is the
example is that my senior year at
Harvard I did what I called systematic
social exploration where there were huge
numbers of people that Wars worth being
around and my search algorithm was
simply put find the most Wow yeah yeah
really like the most intellectual and
ambitious people that I could find
so the combate intersection and ask them
you know upon meeting them and like
making that interaction like really
growth for who they thought the people
that were like most likely to have this
really dramatic long-term effect on
humanity was and once you do that two or
three times you know you say you find
some great person you ask them ho like
who's you know like we'd have a sort of
powerful long-term impact they give you
three names say you find that person you
ask to them who do you think is like
most likely to have just powerful
long-term impact here and they give you
very quickly you get to extraordinary
have quality people life people yes and
through that mechanism I discovered huge
minh really amazing value through I'm
basically like meeting people whose
whose value systems and whose world
views and whose set of actions this
isn't a destroy your trip so a mechanism
like that can almost very simple madness
a very simple mechanism like that can
almost it put so much weight on your
life trajectory that it can alter like
even some of the foundational years of
of that you yeah we're growing up so so
this is the power of mechanisms and this
is a major part of what yeah you care
about it that's right that's right yeah
I love that mechanism that one's we like
calling it also things like the hot 50
like make your list of the top 50 people
that are like vertically networked right
that are more intellectual more
spiritually connected yes you want
whatever so that's the most spiritual
person you know well they'll have some
most spiritual person that they know in
that person like you can you can use the
mechanism for any objective and there's
this sense that there are exploration
strategies
that are undiscovered and so one you
could take this mechanism in client and
it would probably work very well but the
second is you can realize that
generating new mechanisms that are as
powerful as this is an extraordinary
path to social change where ideally the
mechanism can be instantiated in some
system or in some structure and will
basically work as an agent in and of
itself creating a society that's
interesting ly different than it then
would be created in the absence of that
mechanism yeah a lot of that oh my gosh
all right let's okay let's continue
moving on because there's so many things
to unpack let's talk about abstraction
as as deeply as we can here so with
analogies I think we have some really
powerful analogies lined up here one of
them is the way that we engage with
language so why don't you take I mean as
an as someone that literally is an
interlocutor my job is to is to use is
to use an abstraction with language so
you're talking talking talking talking
talking at the end I have parsed what
you've said found the apt most abstract
synthesis yeah and I've left all of the
the saw and of which to's write those
words yeah and so okay so yeah give us
the yeah I'm sorry so here's one thought
you might enjoy is that a lot of
language is basically taking advantage
of Association where when I use a word
that word has been used by umpteen
people before me and when they basically
associated that word with whatever
experience they were having that word
started to acquire connotations or
feelings that were associated with those
experiences and so as a collective we
are developing this collective
conceptual scheme and every time
somebody uses a concept um it will be
associated with something and they'll
start to feel differently about the
concept insofar as that that Association
is held and so we stand here basically
using this language which is taken tons
of like learning of sort of previous
generations you know as they basically
create a conceptual scheme that's
aligned with reality and allows for the
making of Prague
it allows for the quick and concise
description of whatever it is that we're
engaging with and internalizing that
linguistic scheme can interpret with
concepts things that would be
extraordinarily difficult to model
otherwise and so you can see this is
sort of a collective representation but
the tragedy is that if you're interested
in volatility or in growth everyone is
now embedded in the exact same sort of
large-scale conceptual representation it
is forced to represent every object that
they experience with the same words the
same words where's the outliers where's
the differences where's the mimetic
parallax like how do you escape it's
like one where's the differences great
so it's allowed to say oh yeah well you
know the way that can be spoken is not
the true way where there's the sense
that the conceptual scheme is like
insufficient or in the way of the
descriptions of the experiences that are
most worthwhile and you'll often find
that by you know engaging with something
conceptually you've nailed yourself down
to a particular way of thinking about it
which used to be amorphous and
ungrounded and in its you know sort of
potential had sort of a larger space of
possibility then after you conquer ties
that with a particular set of phrases or
ways of thinking about it and so in
creativity you would like to basically
reject your conceptual scheme in some
interesting way and in undoing the
assumptions that have been made by the
collective representation have a hope
have a chance of generating something
new and valuable and so I'm interested
in the connection of new concepts how
might your culture so yeah exactly I in
the sense that um countercultural tends
to be reactionary that's one sort of
easy way to be creative which is
standard like let's invert the value
system of whatever it is that we're
interacting with and there are many many
forms of counterculture but if you
invert in front of every single cultural
experience you have you have an
automatic generator of very different
kinds of experience yeah so you can see
you can see like Nietzsche and master
morality or you can see Satanism as the
sort of inversion of quite canonical
Christian values as a generator of new
religious systems or of new value
systems and there's this like you know
interesting space of possible religious
value systems the article
out but you could try to design new
modes of feeling by asking oh well
here's the way that they choose to feel
on all these things what if I did the
exact opposite of what they do in the
face of it so instead of it is sort of
Buddhist well let's empty our minds of
all thoughts how do we induce a
hypomania that is an extremely fast
stream of thoughts that is an extremely
powerful an emotive stream of thoughts
yeah and make that our our practice as
opposed to emptiness
so I guess think there's a space of
possibilities this exposed via inversion
but it's say that abstraction in
language is from that foundational so
like how do we get to these words or
these concepts like where did it come
from well often you will have some
experience and then you'll have a very
similar experience then they'll have a
very similar experience and he attached
the same label to all of those
experiences you can tie them to one
another you know that's why eight
billion of us can talk about things like
chairs and cars exactly exactly so you
know this chair is usually defined
functionally it's like based on the way
in which you sit in it and it's similar
to this chair it's someone in that chair
like every chair pulls in information
from every other chair you've ever
experienced and lets you know exactly
how to interact with it in a way that's
well very very useful right so there's
this sort of early form of
conceptualization which is the metaphor
so when you make a metaphor you say oh
this thing is like that thing I could
point at this chair and say oh well it's
like that here maybe have different
names for each chair but it's like it's
like this it's like that it's kind of
like this and it's inefficient to have
to like sort of save a metaphor oh you
know it's kind of like a book shopper
it's kind of like this is wrong together
we have specific names for all of those
things over and over again
so eventually people will just create a
new concept and they'll say well all of
the things that are like that thing I'm
gonna call this and they all have a word
for it and that word will let people
seamlessly do transfer across everything
that's labeled with that word like a
neologism for a chair that can also
double as a bed I something like that is
we can add words to the vocab that for
for objects that can be redesigned and
repurposed and stuff
so there's two there's two things here I
think that are really
critical one of the things is that it's
it's it's thanks to the hundred plus
billion humans before us that slowly but
surely figured out how to communicate
yeah we're gonna build a language that
we're super grateful for and also that
it's all about relationships the
relationship between the words that we
say the relationships between the
objects that we have between the humans
and so that's such a critical component
of this yeah I feel that sub like every
sentence is usually here are some
entities that exist and here's how they
relate to one another and ideally you'd
find a nice way to represent the objects
in the relations between them anyway
that were searchable or experienceable
um ever since that like for most
sentences there's a nice mathematical
relationship that you can see the
sentence as representing whether it's
you know if you if you look at this
variable this variable increases this
other variable it'll go it'll go up or
it'll go down and we talk about you know
how to improve things by saying oh well
actually if you improve this thing this
other thing will improve and there's a
simplistic cause a little relationship
between the two variables that we
described you know we hope that like
time spent lifting like increases the
amount of muscle mass increases you know
the amount of week that you can list you
see Association after Association after
Association we believe it right and so
someone can convey to you that concept
that's like oh how do I increase this
this objective this number how do I
accomplish this task and they'll
describe a set of relations to you I
will take this object perform this
operation take this object prints
operation and you'll see your number go
up and often these relationships are
complex like you know they're say
they're quadratic where if you go some
distance it gets worse
but if you go farther it gets better and
as soon as you introduce the simplest
non-linearity your ability to describe
the relationship it starts to decay
where you can't say that in a very
simple simple way and that's why you use
math like you said of quadratics yeah
exactly exactly but you'll have like
many different concepts that all point
to this whether it's the sort of
adaptive valley
right so you know you changed a little
bit and you know you end up in the
valley oh well that changes be bad but
the inference might just be an
assumption that there's a linear
relationship between what you're
changing and the thing that you're
trying to get to for it and if you
pushed farther you have realized that
out of the valley there's there's much
more than you'd expect him yes and so
people get into all of these sort of
terrible beliefs because they'll make
some simple assumption about our
relationship where they tried something
they got worse they tried something was
painful was hard and the feedback loops
weren't fast enough mmm we're like you
know dieting is a wonderful example of
this sort of slow feedback loop you know
maybe you feel better and you know three
or four days or in weeks or in a month
um being too slow
and so because they don't see the
feedback immediately they assume that
their actions aren't having a strong
impact that's what's not just
intellectual it's visceral where their
their visual visceral experience will
response to it is in the stopa manner
Jack loop and if the dopamine is not
triggered and and isn't clearly like
sort of credit assigning to the thing
that they had done they don't want to do
it and so I guess like accross the
spectrum of human behavior you have this
this really physically instantiated
mathematical assumption that I'm team
cases and is incorrect and and that
manifests is like this large-scale
behavioral control problem yeah we're
gonna get to that behavior control
problem in a little bit too as we talk
about the compressing how to learn and
compressing execution okay but let's hit
this on the way temporal abstraction
abstraction of time because this is some
two examples here that I just want to
bring up one of them is that when we
plan things like this show starting you
know are you arriving at 6 o'clock it
was at you know that mean six ish it
doesn't mean 602 and 42 seconds you know
etc so we have things and it's like you
were like you were torta to me before we
started like you would show up 30
minutes or 60 minutes late right things
like that um so we have that abstraction
time but I think an even more
interesting abstraction of time for some
reason is our salience our our
understanding of salience with time
because I feel as though in
after one day of life you really
remember maybe the best thing from that
day after a month of life you remember
the best thing from that month after a
whole life how many best things do you
remember after a whole life that's yeah
that's real there's a socata mental sort
of point to this sort of peak and rule I
think we replicate but basically the
parts of an experience that you remember
or some small subset of the entire
experience yeah there's a sense that
memory has to grapple with time in this
way and in part it's tragic that there
aren't like nice ways to refer to your
memory at different points in time but
basically like it's a very efficient
system for decision-making where if you
had to remember every single two-week
period in the in your past as if it was
the last two weeks
there wouldn't be capacity and so our
mind has to find ways to deal with these
foundational limitations and around how
efficiently it can do information
processing and it tends to abstract as a
response to the sense that there's this
huge amount of information from which
you could draw the entirety of your life
experience and it somehow has to
compress that experience in a way that
can direct your action right now and so
in a given moment you have a few safe
locks in working memory and there's very
little space there right seven plus or
minus five
yeah well depending on how what kind of
objects are dealing with okay sure sure
sure
in case of numbers I think what
somebody's an example name and basically
the need to compress every bit of
information that's relevant to some
mental operation is this is really
damning for our ability to make
high-quality decisions and opti in
contexts where maybe they're like
sixteen relevant facts but you can only
think about three or four of them
simultaneously or there are creative
solutions but they require the
integration of five different complex
parts and you can't hold five in your
mind at the same time it's only hold two
in your mind at the same time I think
they're undoing mathematical problems
that are actually trivial if you can fit
all five like you know objects all five
variables in and their relationships in
memory at the same time
but if you ever can't get to that number
it's almost impossible to solve the
problem and so and so one question is
like how do we create an effective
source sort of sources of external
memory which will let us continue to
make decisions on the basis of more
information that we're capable of
processing in a given moment and this is
pretty good at doing the externalizing
of memory but it doesn't make the
association that's right that's right
and if you want to be creative you have
to hold them in your mind simultaneously
and so yes one important sort of
valuable proposition in creating
creative intelligent machines is that
there are umpteen solutions that are
right on the sort of the horizon of our
working memories ability to generate
those solutions but because of sort of
fundamental limitations humans aren't
capable of of thinking the slightly
higher dimensional thought and if you
like relax that limitation and there's a
huge amount of creative action that that
could come just for immediately there
are like umpteen concepts that my
algorithms will learn on a daily basis
that I would never have discovered in
part because I don't know how to attend
to multiple parts of again image
simultaneously I don't know how to
attend a huge amounts of sort of
information in a corpus simultaneously
in a way that would let me integrate
that information with you know the other
parts of it and so when we design an
algorithm let's say is doing transfer
from one situation to another you know
it learns in one domain and it tries to
generalize to another domain and it's
combining umpteen parts of the things
that it's learned in generating its
solutions there is this creative
interface for problem solving that feels
much more powerful more potent on the
access of working memory but in human
creativity that he was also obviously a
deeply important the expansion of
working memory comes out of abstracting
properly yes where if you take some
complex idea you've been struggling with
that you've seen in many places a
pattern you've seen in many places you
can turn it into a word that word will
acquire much less space in working
memory and wills fast also start to
accumulate associations as you begin to
use it maybe like a word fractal because
that has shown
many what for yeah well everything is
like recursion is one of the most
powerful concepts conceivable where self
reference is one of the few things that
toppled this sort of beautiful abstract
mathematical systems that we had like
Gottlob Frank writes down this beautiful
algebra like there's always missions of
self reference they create infinities
that the undo and Google powerful
systems we've created
um but yeah fractal and version that
gets hard to point at these things
without you know a word that says oh
well here it is in this context here it
isn't that company as these other
complex all of them share the exact same
mathematical structure and I guess that
I have an appreciation for the creation
of a new concept that efficiently lets
you interact it with other concepts and
so when you hit the limitations of your
working memory you try to compress
through information in a new and
hopefully interesting and productive way
yes
which will let you generate ideas that
couldn't have been thought before like
one simple like I want to generate
something that's never been thought is
I'm going to create three or four new
concepts that you know say it took a
book to describe but that is a simple
pattern that you can see in multiple
places and in thinking with them
simultaneously well be almost guaranteed
to think thoughts that I've never
thought before mm-hm
yeah and we're gonna get to that toward
some of the creativity at the end I want
to also make sure that people know so
within the links that are in the bio
there's you have so much breakdown of
these modeled systems yeah yeah and one
of them they thought was really
interesting was the actual breakdown of
the properties of abstraction conceptual
rather than concrete general rather than
specifically compressed representation
like we were just saying an abstraction
is a hierarchical compression that the
lower-level objects don't get the
attention in the space but that the
synthesis is do that's right yeah so
what I offered was eight definitions of
the exact same concept and what tends to
happen is people will offer one
definition of a concept that people have
defined in many different ways and in
confusing those definitions for one
another they actually won't be able to
know what one another is describing or
talk
about and often the definitions will be
contradictory so one thing I do in the
book is basically with each definition
say a way a given example of abstraction
that violates the definition and so
you'll find that most definitions of
words are sort of reaching for the fact
that the word is actually used in many
interestingly different ways and has a
connotation acquires a connotation and
is actually this very high-dimensional
like simultaneous like a word is a felt
sense like a way of feeling about a
thing as well as a particular fact about
the thing as well usually as like many
sort of different definitions of
whatever it's representing in giving all
of the definitions you can attain
conceptual clarity and when you get the
clarity about what's being said or
what's being thought it's possible to
make progress and I think so much
progress is actually well you have a
concept that conflates many different
positions and people will just talk to
us one another and I think that a
quality example of this is this freewill
debate people have over over and over
and over again where they actually have
instantiate in this concept in very
different ways from one another and they
switch between the definitions yeah and
they don't know that they're switching
mmm and this is beautiful
Arkana sort of the Motte Bailey problem
and debates where people will have you
know the very defensible version of
their idea and then like sort of you
know virtually really holds but much
less defensible version yeah I mean
people will attack the you know
expansive version of the idea those oh
no no no it's only this definition and
then as soon as the you know the people
go away they say oh actually it also
means all of these other things and with
concepts that are like you know you
abusing abstraction and that they're
conflating unlike things with one
another it's very easy to say oh well
you know here's you know my my you know
religious scheme or system and it'll
have all these consequences and some of
the oh like what about this sort of that
if they question it you'll say oh
actually it's just this one thing that
is very defensible and often it's like
possible to do useful emotional work
that way but I think many debates like
fights that people have look a lot like
this
yeah and this is this can be some of the
issues with having a space in goal word
like free will or like a simulation or
or like substrate or whatever the words
are is just that it and you add power to
the word by by adding different
implementations now by basically making
it more expensive and that's what you
did with breaking down abstraction into
the eight definition yeah that's right
and so I I agree that this is a really
great way to do it actually that should
be one of the things that's listed on
the wikipedia pages for these things
like I think it's actually listed on you
know multiverse right so multiverse and
then you see like max take marks
breakdown of it and I think there's like
another maybe Brian greens breakdown of
it right so there's which is actually
really helpful because then that's the
levels of definitions of that and
abstraction okay let's hit on the word
transfer for us allows for efficient
modeling and learning where upon
encountering a situation and intelligent
being or system can bring pattern seen
in data and problems from the past to
bear on the new situation and you plant
you like I love this part moving an idea
out and across domains I that's such a
such a critical thing like the anti
disciplinary that's right it's the
creation of the unity of knowledge and
up team ways where there's this vague
realization that the boundaries between
these domains are really somewhat
arbitrary and mathematics is a front and
center example a place where you'll
define a relationship and it has a shape
or as a form and that relationship will
exist in umpteen academic disciplines
and the failure to do transfer from say
the properties of that function to those
other disciplines is a tragedy exciting
necklace.the seen talib is a beautiful
example of taking a very simple idea
okay so he has a be federal but but he
also is fooled by randomness in the
black swan yeah yeah and the wax on for
example he will describe a situation
where there's a power law distribution
that is their extremes and the extremes
that are the outliers they are really
really large which you know has the as
example is obviously the financial
crisis yes there are umpteen examples of
these power lines for needed demands you
know the amount of money that is made by
individual
another good example where because of
the properties of that distribution you
can actually say that it makes sense to
act very differently in the face of that
distribution then then if you have some
normally distributed outcome like height
right so what he does is take a very
simple statistical principle sort of the
normal distribution and that you know in
the abstract the distribution or
something that is made and he contrasts
it with this power law distribution and
he shows that in three or four different
areas and social science and economics
you know we used two disciplines when
you look at data and data has this form
you have to draw dramatically different
conclusions so he has extremists and
versus media acha stance so the world
were they're complex interactions and
where they're basically our power law
distributed outcomes versus the world
where there are simple interactions and
I think of that this this idea in
probability theory is very general but
almost every idea in probability theory
is that general where you can see
probability and statistics as meta
science in that like our practical
epistemology is saying oh well this is
true statistically you know we've seen
it many times in the past we're looking
at a similar distribution now we expect
to be able to generalize and where the
answers to the problem of induction are
like when can we generalize from the
past to the future is the problem of
these statistical tools or of machine
learning and it's how we come to truth
and so in every domain where we think we
believe things that are true the
standards for evidence look statistical
and often these probably probabilistic
models have implications and so I see
him as doing the work of taking this one
idea out and across domains yes and
there is a huge amount of work you know
intellectual cognitive work that could
be done taking well certainly like every
major idea in probability theory out and
across domains but also in mathematics
and the sciences and even there's
criticism domain
the interconnectedness of I think
especially yeah yeah that's right yeah
like often like the way that spiritual
people will use abstraction in order to
create power inside of their concepts
because the sense of awe that comes from
looking at the generality and the
concept it's very powerful so so often
you know like you read about dualism in
the II Ching yeah beginning versus the
Yong they're all of these like sort of
like high abstract like this applies to
almost everything you've ever chaos of
order and the beautiful thing is when
you learn something about a concept
that's very very gentle yeah it applies
to umpteen situations and you get to
feel the power of the update to umpteen
aspects of your worldview simultaneously
yes it becomes so difficult to interact
with improvements to your worldview that
are local and I feel merely yeah yeah
and so you have to experience them as
the concrete abstract so a particular
example has to be an example of a more
general principle and in updating the
general principle you experience an
update across all of your experience oh
it's so beautiful
Jasha the way that a really powerful
update a general update can just update
your worldview across domains because
it's enough that's right I'm very
applicable every time I learn something
about heavy tail distributions seriously
your power laws all this time young like
these types of things
yeah the beauty of like the internet
unless I know I know we've still so much
talk about the power of representation
where if you represent your world in a
way that makes these updates easily
accessible and possible yeah
then everything is fascinating and it's
correct for it to feel fascinating yeah
yep and that's so critical that's like
being in awe I love it okay let's hit on
let's hit all this religious by the way
yeah the feeling of awe that you're
feeling
yeah it's spiritual yeah because you
feel the heights and the generality
right and they will depend on that
mechanism over and over and over again
to create the feeling of scale and awe
look at the way that Christ is all
things the wave
you know God has seen this the creator
of that's not and the other being use of
infinity anyway sorry yeah yeah yeah
okay okay all right
these things are these things kind of
fit together one of the aspects of what
we mentioned this earlier but just that
as we as in the machine intelligence age
that we come are using the the the
appendages that are kind of outside of
us for now like computers for now we
want to make them more associative also
the appendages will soon be inside of us
and so it potentially will see what end
of that happening but I want to know
compressing how to learn and compressing
execution this is extremely important
especially in today's attention economy
of beep boop bop bop bop bop up just
like always getting Bing Bing Bing even
also the business models around the
attention economics so to be able to
actually focus to be able to follow on
momentum as you're already going and
just stay hyper focused in that to go
counterculture to social norms actually
focused and diffuse thinking they kind
of remind me of sparse versus dense
rewards so let's again reinforce them
right it's cute so that because I was
just from yesterday with Tony oh yeah
yeah high-dimensional versus low
dimensional yeah yeah that's I mean
there is plenty of trade structure you
can talk about it so much fun structure
yeah yeah so I think of that compressing
learning and compressing execution are
examples of attempts on my end to build
a concrete model of every major system
that I engage with and there's this huge
diff when you come to a situation having
already written down everything that you
think about that thing where now if I
learn something about learning it's not
as if I'm engaging with that space for
the first time I actually can add it to
this comprehensive sort of set of
knowledge that I've built about how to
learn effectively and when someone comes
to me and is like oh well you know in
our education system here is our process
I can say here are 15 principles of how
to learn effectively that if you
implemented simultaneously would almost
certainly be too dramatic
and somebody's ability to learn whatever
it is that they're working on um and so
I think of it basically like writing
down what you think about like every you
know major domain that you interact with
over and over and over again is a very
efficient way to build a worldview and
that's the spaced repetition - let's hit
that slide while we're while we're here
- yeah and that's the fourth one so I
would like to basically have my
knowledge build on itself over time yes
as opposed to via the sort of
vicissitudes of memory fall out of my my
worldview just because I've forgotten it
and 15 principles of how to learn
compressing can potentially does
actually literally rock it ones
trajectory upward in terms of their
ability to fall out follow a North Star
and execute on that and doing things
like spaced repetition is what holds on
to and this is one of the principle yeah
that's right so yes my learning process
at least for textbook reading was
typically I would sit down with the
timer I would make sure that I in
reading each page wasn't taking more
than like five to six minutes per
failure so this is of technical books
you know book like machine learning and
pattern recognition there's a lot of
text on the on each page that's really
small
and I would first of all rewrite
everything that I read damn so you
didn't read a page and you think you
know what was on the page but you find
very quickly if you try to write down
what was on the page that you didn't
hold huge amounts of in memory you
didn't see some of it and when you try
to reconstruct it that's revealed to you
yes so this this ability to rewrite
what's on the page also forces you to
pay attention in the first place yes and
then you compare what you wrote to what
actually exists afterwards and you
realize oh well um here are all of the
holes in my ability to read so I feel
like I was in practice learning how to
read your hand for the first time a lot
of ways right because you read and you
think that you know what's there that's
there and you you know you talk to
someone and asking oh like what did you
read yeah yeah yeah
it depends because you can actually get
a synthesis of a book that if you can
say to the author and they would just be
like that was better than what I wrote
on my book jacket yeah and that's right
yeah that happened that have take you
take it seriously yes that absolutely
happens if you take it seriously and
this beautiful we've had a guest that's
sat down after we read their bio and
they're like I'm gonna use that as my
bio I have an appreciation for
reconstruction so basically like I like
reading a sex book for saying two hours
each morning will like right thus
document and in the reconstructing yet
well like have written hundreds of pages
which is basically like the textbook but
in my own words right and there's a
stickiness to that it's hard to get from
sort of just like reading straight up
and especially in the absence of extra
nihilistic so he exercises a super super
important you're something saying every
page and you're getting comparable and
and it's like and it's like not that
complicated and then that whole process
happens over a chapter then it happens
over the entire book and then what you
do so not only are you doing you put it
you're gonna put what you learn in argue
yeah you're doing a first reminder from
reading it a second reminder from
writing it then you're doing a third
reminder when you take that and you look
at it the next day yeah and then you do
a fourth reminder when later that day
you teach Alan about it so that's
wonderful actually and then that's a
firewire firewire you're like really
remembering and that way you actually
have information retention versus the
forgetting curve when you don't have
these little firewire reminders I'll
superstar credible also the best thing
to do is read something you're going to
use in your future and in using it get
another set of hits
so I'll read I'm sure you learning text
book and then implement the algorithms
that I read about and it's a much more
detailed and really who unfalsifiable
like version of the algorithm like you
can't lie about whether your code is
working or not and so that's the sort of
concrete representation of your
understanding instantiated code
that ow that feels right grounded okay
and this is one of the most important
things for those they're viewing right
now to retain is that you are really
pursuing your North Stars you're
pursuing finding meaning in life
whatever you find that to be make sure
to repeat do the spaced repetition of
that content that you're reading that
you're analyzing that you're learning
and implementing into your essence on a
space repetition processor that you can
most effectively achieve these dreams
that you set out for on creativity you
have such a good podcast conversation on
this subject generating ideas and we
have another asset for systemising
creativity this is what is your the logo
right this is the logo the creation
system moment of creation the moment of
creation there's so many things here
that you were teaching me that things
like first of all the importance of
mimetics
the idea is propagating across networks
is so critical things like having time
constraints so like if you if you say
every morning 10 minutes I'm gonna write
down ten ideas okay you only get two
ideas down and then there's only two
minutes left the amount of force bite
yeah you're come up with more yeah and
you start to engage to this this
creative state of mind right because
once the ideas start to flow or start to
come there's there's the sense of
there's a tree or a point at which its
natural and flowing and you'll hit a
vein of creative ideation where the
ideas are somewhat similar to each other
but that piggybacking and yet in this
really excited state because you're
looking at something that hadn't existed
before but it's really reasonable to
think of most mental processes as being
similar to physical processes where you
could train it if you had some quality
training regimen and where creativity is
a skill in that there are set of mental
motions that you make a generate
valuable creative ideas and if you can
engage that state of mind over and over
and over and over again as if you are a
creative athlete you're training for
this creative Olympics you would be
capable of performing at a much higher
level basically problem-solving much
more effectively flexibly creatively
than almost anybody else right so I
guess it's it's in part about idea flow
and building up a lifestyle really
around creative ideation in my in my
life but I I think that it's also not
that costly where in ten minutes a day
by generating ten ideas against the
target you will be substantially more
generative certainly than you were
before and well offer the ability to in
the face of any problem say well I can
sit here and in 10 minutes generate 10
different paths or 10 different plans
all of which would basically lead me to
to my goal would be a solution and that
ability to be generative I'm in the face
of a problem is what looks like sort of
resourcefulness in this sort of startup
ecosystem of you is really like what
opens up pathways that are ten times or
a hundred times more efficient yeah then
the pathway that that you would go on by
default you have which breaks you out of
social mores so it's very easy to
complain about the default way of
thinking about something and that's fine
but if you have the ability to generate
mine not beef always think of thinking
about that same problem then it'll it'll
feel natural actually to be frustrated
with a socially collision so many
mechanisms like this and and one of them
is this basically idea Jam that you do
in the morning and just ten ideas in ten
minutes that's a profound one this
actually goes all the way back to like
Thomas Edison this is such a cool point
that he would fall asleep with the rock
that's right in his hand and then as
he's falling asleep the rock would fall
wake him up and he would be in a part
potentially REM sleep or deep sleep and
then he would be in kind of that partly
sleeping partly where you have an
interesting amount of abstract creative
synthesis happening that's right and
then you and then as you wake up you go
oh I'm gonna write that down I would
execute on that yeah maybe all the
moment if like as you're falling asleep
you like jump up and you run to what cuz
you're thinking of the problem right yes
and you start to enter this hypnagogic
in between sleep and wakefulness state
of mind or emptying of the constraints
that force your representation of
reality to
rational or reasonable those constraints
start to loosen and so people
consistently have the experience of like
while dreaming being able to conceive of
things that would have been
inconceivable in daily life and it's
because when you're in wakefulness you
basically are engaged with a bunch of
constraining mechanisms that stop you
from thinking particular kinds of
thought that are misaligned
the truth is that the mind that
generates your experiences while you're
dreaming is the exact same mind that
generates your experience of day-to-day
reality and there is this sort of
flexibility in the space of things to a
brain can represent that's strongly
curtailed by basically you would need to
engage with reality in a concrete way
out a concrete basis so this this sense
that you can engage with that state
intentionally and use it to generate
creative ideas as part of what is sort
of called the fuse of thinking your
brain would go to a default mode right
so you want you mind wandering
you know the open-ended walk you know
sitting in the shower experience and you
have prep you want to prime before
you're walking before your shower by
like I'm looking at these for 20 minutes
and then go for a walk and things like
your proper 20 minutes a don't go to a
shower and not with headphones on your
walk and not that's right where your
attention is then yeah I'm grounded
exactly exactly are you and like
creativity hacking it's so beautiful
uh yeah I'm upgrading enhancing I know I
think that a lot of them do you feel
like hacks you know your brain happens
to work this way so act in such and such
a way and you'll get the outcome that
you want I think that that is it's
pretty accurate where you say we have
some understanding in the system we can
like force you know us ourselves into
this this pathway and what won't be more
generative um so some of it looks like
default mode okay I think that if people
just took showers more like you know
like water you speed and and blessing
the spirit of giving us the water to be
able to Creek and tonight and to bathe
in yeah the blessing it yeah that's a
critical part of this process they would
be more generative and they basically
are like engaging with my states that I
consistently produce on the KY quality
in new ideas
yes consistently consistently the
mechanisms that can launch our
trajectory upward faster these
mechanisms like you mentioned with the
worldview updating like you're
mentioning with creativity hacking I
think these mechanisms are so crucial
you know some jingle okay I just wanted
I wanted I just wanted to say it's just
such a fascinating way of perceiving the
world through you like if I carry ously
through your worldview right now yeah
that's like part yeah what I feel so
there are sixteen elements one is
basically asked if I was in the mind of
this other person this this identity
right so if I was an economist what
would I say if I was a mathematician
we'll know say if I was you know Alan
what I say if I was Peter kilo I was
going mastic if I was Donald Trump what
would I do
and how would I solve my problem there's
this some sense that we can model other
minds and you know it's internal it's
like inside our mind is a little
simulator of the other person and if you
engage with that simulator and ask what
they would say it generates a very
different response than your response
which is super interesting since like
it's all it happening inside your head
but it's super useful if you want
different perspectives to generate
creative ideas in the face of your
problem
and asking what you know every major
academic field would say about your
problem basically does transfer from the
concepts the conceptual schemes in those
academic fields so you know if the
economist is thinking in terms of
incentives and in terms of deadweight
loss in terms of marginality and
resources and resource constraints and
then principal-agent problems in game
theory like bringing in those concepts
to your problem gives you very different
solutions than engaging with the
statisticians notion of variance and of
bias scent of of the distribution that
represents the objects and like I guess
there are all of these conceptual
schemes which have predictive power in
umpteen contexts that you can bring to
bear on your problem on your situation
or whatever it is that you're thinking
about one of the best things that we can
do I think is to be able to abstractly
reason a bunch of worldviews at the same
time that's right and yeah in this
ensemble model yeah so I Samba the most
that's honorable um because then what
you're doing is you're seeing how
somebody from the African continent from
the Europe area from the South American
area China Asian area of the world sees
a specific issue that's right and then
ever you can interesting yeah
someone that's old someone that's young
something that's poor some that are rich
that's right that's right yeah and then
they convert totally from solutions and
then in that that's it the creativity is
one component but then also it's
interesting some what some people say
that oh is that kind of schizophrenic a
little bit so that word is so strangely
has so much bad connotation but I think
that it is kind of schizophrenic to be
balancing all these different worldviews
at the same time and not necess is a
reality when there's eight billion views
on reality so this is a tough this is a
tough thing to be able to figure out
well water certain molecular structure
so we can probably objectively agree
that it is bad so these inter subjective
truth yeah things like that yeah okay
for our second episode we'll we'll dive
deeper into more of this couple quick
questions on the way out it's been so
awesome what do you think happens
pre-birth and post death interesting
so there's the materials for dr. must
answer I don't know if that's the one
that you're interested in there's this
since the time as we've represented it
with modern physics is well it's what
presented us with a lot of issues so one
is its reversibility to is this question
of like whether the reality were and was
generated simultaneously that is are all
times basically static in some external
world or whether it's being like fluidly
generated so yeah I guess like well
there's a sense that like we are a part
of the universe and so everything that
we do is basically interacting with
other parts of our universe
and the things interacted with things
previously in order to generate us
so there's question of like oh well like
what is identity and like what does it
mean for me to continue to exist there
on certain ways in which I stop
continuing to exist certainly like in
our reality upon death the dumpee ways
in which what I do is is like you know
echoing an eternity
you know the sound gladiator and this
this sort of like want for a legacy R to
live on and denial if deficit was this
powerful generator of meaning mm-hmm but
we hope in part is like to you know make
like you know like anti-aging and like
longevity and life extension happen in a
way that like sort of stops the sort of
important since the death is
ever-present but obviously like you know
our fear and frustration of death is
like in part a function of us being
these of all creatures that well like
don't like it when our line gets cut
so okay next question yeah or with yeah
Ron let's retire that question oh well
oh well we'll have to talk about that
two cents on that I don't think it's
really important what happens before or
what happens after cuz all we know is
right now that that question is more
like none of our business and like with
Jeremy mentioned on you know we're
extending life and we want to stop the
aging process you know we're just we're
just gonna celebrate what we know it
doesn't matter it doesn't matter where
you come from or where you going I think
it totally matters the birthplace that's
where we disagree where you enter into
this beautiful spiritual experience of
being a human that that location matters
and then the journey matters and then
the ending matters the whole process
it's all a random chance on a wicked
deck of cards weaving serpents or the
other alternative is that it's extremely
meaningful and you had already decided
the lessons that you were coming in here
to learn there's a lot of also spiritual
thoughts about that okay are we alone in
the cosmos uh yeah I think that it's
well unlikely statistically but it's
hard to say exactly what the parameters
should be and our model of whether or
not we're alone is updating dramatically
over time where we encounter new
concepts so I think one very powerful
concept simulation is an indicator
that's possible for us to receive very
powerful updates to how we think our
world has been created I've learned to
what our world is constituted of yes and
I think that the only place that makes
sense to be is on the side of this vast
array of unknown unknowns where I expect
our conceptual scheme that is the way
that we interpret our reality to change
dramatically certainly in the face of
more powerful intelligences capable of
representing the world in ways that we
can't imagine and
it would be someone arrogant to assume
that like this particular you know truth
is definitely the case and so you know
I'm going to like make permanent
decisions on its basis it's very
important to be sufficiently meta and
update industry in the face of new
evidence and expect there to be dramatic
and interesting new evidence so a
concept that that followed on from
simulations I guess you know both
Schilling Robin Hanson like doing
amazing work in the space one of Robins
ideas this this great filter is a very
fascinating concept asking where are we
so ya know we don't see you know life on
other planets does that mean it's likely
that we're likely to you know say it via
some form of existential risk kill
ourselves before we reach the scale of
civilization that we think we would
naturally reach that concept didn't
really exist say 10 to 20 years ago we
didn't think in those terms and so I
expect us to both generate and like new
and fascinating concepts but also like
new technical paradigms in which we
could conceive of ourselves having been
created where like computer science and
like quality computers is relatively
recent and in the absence of that frame
it's hard to say imagine simulation ISM
and well I don't know we have sort of
creator-god
of umpteen social spiritual religions
and the similarity between simulation
and creationism on those similarities
are like a parent right huge so in some
senses we had many concepts so that the
sort of simulation is a sort of bares
analyze them for a long long time in a
lot of ways it's like a very new way of
conceiving of things and you know if
there had been like a different ordering
to the way technologies were invented I
maybe would have had computation before
we had physics and physics would be
based in computation and we would have
well the sort of simulation much earlier
then it happened to come something like
it um so I see this sort of conceptual
progress as having dramatic turns and I
expect there to be more dramatic turns
in the future and do you think this is a
simulation I would put the preponderance
of my weight on basically this is a
concept of that I actually don't
we have and in the face of conceptual
progress maybe humans will end up with a
concept of what it is that exists but
there are umpteen foundational and soft
problems certainly in the sort of the
nature of information and in the space
of ways in which worlds can be created
that make me think that well one frame
is that oh whoa
if simulation is possible there are
umpteen worlds it's really likely that
we're like in the world that was
simulated not in the world that was real
but they may come along someday some
other concepts which is another way in
which worlds could be created which
maybe isn't computational which vastly
out you know produces the same set of
worlds that we would have expected under
a simulation and so I would say that
almost all of my weight lies in this
sort of space of unknown concepts which
you know this sort of epistemological
path we've been on the scientific method
hopes to eventually sort of find
foundation for discover you know the
dreams certainly of physics is
understanding what happened before the
Big Bang and sort of thing I think of it
in the face of future knowledge it's
like easy for me to put weight on that
which we do not know exists unknown
unknowns yes very excited to be able to
discover those as we keep pushing last
question yeah what is the most beautiful
thing in the world
Oh climbing the heights of abstraction
that's real it's a basically
transcendent and the highest levels
conceivable I think is Creek capable of
generating all of reality in a moment I
said that was a good one
climbing the heights of abstraction
that's such a good one and it is
transcendent it's extremely transcended
if you can synthesize all that is into
some beautiful abstraction film a short
video a meme of a function that
generates reality so what simulation
here is is saying that well you can ask
which one's more real but there's this
abstract function that's being used to
create our reality which is a data
generating function so it's a function
where you know it will create the data
points in light of some transition
function and if you look at that
function you say well is our reality the
data that's being generated or is it
more real to reference the generator
itself mm-hmm right as opposed to the
output that it happens to be spitting
out right and there are between ways in
which the abstract reality is more real
then the quote-unquote real reality and
it's certainly more general and more
beautiful then then the data that
happens to exist so referencing the
generator that's right versus what is
being generated that's right yeah that's
so cool all right this has been
ridiculous Jeremy we have to have you
back round two will have to happen
sometime soon this has been such a
fascinating conversation right yeah so
grateful for you coming on the show yeah
thank you thank you yeah all right
and for all those that tuned in we
greatly appreciate you we'd love to hear
your thoughts in the comments below on
the episode check out the links also in
the bio the AI Google link the sis
creativity link the model systems link
check those out share them with your
friends the LinkedIn Jeremy's LinkedIn
profile get talking to more people your
friends family coworkers people online
on social media about abstraction and
about creativity and about alignment get
talking about these things more get
sharing about them more huge shadow to
Ron Vargas for producing and directing
thank you very much
and support the artists the
entrepreneurs the organizations around
the world that you believe in supports
simulation our links our bill will help
us grow and prosper and go and build the
future everyone manifest your dreams
into the world thank you so much for
tuning in and we will see you soon peace
[Music]
[Music]